Speaker 1: All right, let's continue here.
Yeah, he just had too much going on. Let's go
to John from Jersey. John, what's going on today?
Speaker 6: Hey, David. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Speaker 6: So you've been
talking a lot lately about anti-Semitism, which
is a subject I think about a lot. So I'm a Copt,
which is a Christian ethno religious group, mostly
from Egypt. Yes. So growing up around other Copts,
I also heard some dark anti-Semitic comments like,
you know, a lot of it with the whole, you know,
Christ killer or sometimes, you know, they have
the evil eye. They're pale with no soul. Yeah.
And as vile and as vile as these comments are.
What really puzzles me is the phenomenon of the
typical tropes like, you know, they stick together
and help each other. You know, they're cheap,
you know? And and what's hypocritical
about this is a lot of these, like,
common tropes are actually traits that are in
the Coptic community and they're almost like
revered except, you know, you're not call
cheap, you're called like frugal and like,
you know, crafty and things like that. You're
not called, you know, the something bad about
sticking together. No, you're you know, you're
part of a community. Right. So I just want to ask.
Speaker 1: One of the funny ones. Sorry. Sorry
to interrupt, but one of the funny ones is,
you know, when people go, oh, Jews, they
just love money. It's like, right. Black
people hate money. White people hate money.
Italian people hate money. Jews are the ones
that love money. It's just. It's all so stupid.
Speaker 6: Yes. I mean I mean, it's it's very
transparent and hypocritical. Why? Why is it that
it's something that's that's still a trend among,
you know, really most most people.
Speaker 1: Which part is a trait that
having the anti-Semitic beliefs or what?
Speaker 6: Well, I guess I guess the the
like hate for Jews. Like what? What is it? What
is it that makes Jews so unique or the focal
point of of, you know, the whole world, really.
Speaker 1: There's a bunch of factors here,
so I'll I'll list some of them. Okay.
There are historical factors which.
Blaming Jews for thousands of years has been
a shorthand that can be used whenever there's
a problem. Is it? They're responsible for the
plague or they're responsible for killing Jesus,
or they're responsible for the American college
and universities becoming left wing, whatever. So,
first of all, it's just it's been a shorthand for
a long time, too. As you mentioned, many of the
tropes actually sort of apply to everyone. But
and so when so it's very easy to say, oh, well,
you know, Jews love money and are cheap. It's like
most people like money and try to avoid spending
more money than they need to. But when it's
only applied to one group, you can very easily
find what you're looking for. That's a second
thing. Third thing, there is a difference with
some Jews. Remember, there's some Jews are
darker skinned, lighter skinned, whatever.
In Western societies, it's true that in many
cases you can't tell by looking at someone,
whether they're Jewish. Obviously, most Jews
aren't wearing a yarmulke or pay us or, you know,
all these different things. So you can't tell
when you look at someone. And to some of these
anti-Semites, that becomes part of why they are
targeted, because it's seen almost as part of
the deception. You know, they walk around among
us and you can't even tell who's who. Someone's
a woman. You can tell by looking at them. If
someone's black, you can tell by looking at them,
etc.. So it almost feeds upon its own trope
about the idea of deception and hiding out in
plain sight. So all these different little
historical and modern realities. And then
there's another thing which people love to
talk about this, or why are Jewish folks
overrepresented in some industries and they love
to talk about law or entertainment or whatever.
Right. There is a historical discrimination reason
why that's the case. Jews were banned for so long
and in so many places from participating in so
many industries that there was this de facto
push to concentrate in industries where you can
not necessarily have to physically engage with
certain industries in particular ways. And it's
because of discrimination that you now see some
of that phenomena today, not because of any grand
conspiracy to control industries, as anti-Semites
often say, it's because of discrimination
where Jews were crossed off from a whole bunch
of industries. You can't be here. You can't be
here. You can't be here. Okay, well, what's left?
Speaker 6: Right. Right. That's something similar
to a lot of other trades or professions like,
you know, Irish-Americans in the law
enforcement community, things like that. Yep.
Thanks, David. Thanks for giving me your take
on this. I appreciate that. Another question.
Speaker 1: You know, we are out of time.
Speaker 6: Okay. Thanks for taking my call.
Speaker 1: Your first one was good, though, so
I really appreciate it. All right, everybody,
we're going to go to a break. Sorry I wasn't able
to get to everybody, but we will take calls again.